[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle semaine nous sommes le 10
octobre voici les titres de votre
journal quotidien d'information ce lundi
nous irons notamment à guyancourt où le
maire françois de ligne et vient
d'annoncer sa démission le socialiste
était arrivé à ce poste en 2002 nous
verrons les raisons de son départ
pendant ce temps à maurepas ont célébré
le commerce de proximité des animations
ont eu lieu tout au long du week-end
dans cette commune mais aussi dans
plusieurs autres en france la résistance
s'organise face aux grands centres
commerciaux et puis en culture à buc
nouvelle édition du festival de la bande
dessinée et nouveau succès les amateurs
du neuvième art étaient présents en
nombre pour rencontrer les auteurs
s'étaient également ce week end
l'actualité de ce début de semaine c'est
donc la démission de françois de ligne
et le maire vient de tenir cet après
midi une conférence de presse au cours
de laquelle il a expliqué qu'il
souhaitait pas c'est leur passer le
relais au bon moment rappelant qu'il
avait déjà prévenu que ce serait son
dernier mandat il faut savoir préparer
l'avenir sans s'accrocher à son poste
écoutez
il ya une décision de passage de relais
et pourquoi maintenant parce que avec
d'état d'esprit que j'ai indiqué c'est à
dire celui
d'une préparation de l'avenir je sais
que c'est le bon moment parce qu'on va
pouvoir travailler en continuité parce
que la majorité municipale présentera la
candidature de marie christine le tarnec
qui
était déjà dans responsabilités
d'adjoint dans le mandat d'avant vaut
mieux partir quand on est avec une ville
en forme et en forme soi même une page
qui se tourne donc du côté de guyancourt
maire de la commune depuis 2002 le
socialiste françois de ligny avait pris
en cours de mandat la succession de
roland nadeau entré au conseil municipal
en 1989 il avait également officié en
tant qu adjoint chargé de la culture
l'ancien instituteur qui s'était tourné
vers la politique aura également été
conseiller départemental de 2008 à 2015
il ne va pas quitter le conseil de
guyancourt il va également resté
conseiller communautaire jusqu'en 2020 à
saint quentin en yvelines et c'est donc
sa première adjointe marie-christine le
tarnec qui devrait lui succéder
l'élection aura lieu avant le mois à
deux aides décembre je vous propose à
présent hâte d'écouter quelques réaction
est tout d'abord celle de sandrine grand
gang c'est la responsable départementale
du parti socialiste elle a longtemps
travaillé à ses côtés elle va continuer
à travailler avec lui au sein de
l'agglomération
je suis à la fois un petit peu triste
parce qu'on a pris l'habitude de
travailler avec françois de ligne et
depuis depuis quelques années et en même
temps je savais respectueuse de la
décision qu'il a prise assez rare en
politique des hommes politiques qui est
abandonnée de même décidé de mettre un
terme à leur mandat de maire il fait un
pli à la fois dans les pas de deux roues
d'amadou et en même pas il a réussi à
donner sa propre action n'était pas
toujours c'est pas pour ça quand on
arrive après c'était le cas
avant minuit à une blague ou ailleurs
pour hollande à dos on va quand même
l'effort personnalité et contrevenaient
à assure imposer sa marque on peut être
à la fois
parfois très directif on est prêt à
avoir une politique très équilibré en
même temps que très respectueux et
provisions
pour l'agglomération de saint quentin
toujours michel laugier le président
divers droite de saint quentin en
yvelines tiens à saluer son adversaire
michel laugier qui l'an dernier là
emporté face à lui alors des élections
départementales françois de lenny avait
déjà annoncé que c'était son dernier
mandat la seule incertitude c'était de
savoir à quel moment elle allait faire
son annonce à quel moment il allait
passer le relais nous sommes les
meilleurs adversaires puisque déjà nous
avions une commune des communes voisines
annonce avons souvent à travailler
ensemble et puis surtout lorsqu'il y
avait d'autres élections nous étions
face à face voilà avec des succès pour
lui dans son métaux et des succès ont
ensuite eu pour moi dans un deuxième
temps voilà donc je suis pas surpris je
pense qu'il ya de sages décisions
lorsque il faut savoir passer le relais
du côté de l'opposition municipale à
présent écouter le point de vue du chef
de file les républicains ladislas
secours a été lue depuis deux ans à
aiguilles en cours et il ne semble pas
très surpris lui non plus de ce départ
il est derniers mois et des dernières de
l'année comme qui peut compliquer la vie
des sujets brûlants des dossiers
importants
il est très possible que que cela est un
petit peu
touché la gouvernance et monsieur
désigné plus particulièrement il vient
et rythme là on peut le voir de manière
à les progrès lors des conseils
municipaux
frictions au sein de la majorité
quant au groupe modem toujours à
guyancourt son représentant s'est dit
surpris par la date mais pas du contenu
rapportent nos confrères du parisien et
que pensent les habitants de cette
démission de leur mère qui restera je le
rappelle au sein du conseil municipal
mais aussi au sein du conseil
d'agglomération de saint quentin un
micro-trottoir signé patrick jacques de
dixmude et anne-laure l'anguille
basse et ta mère que j'ai apprécié dans
des circonstances un peu particulières
ou sincère d'un établissement scolaire
donc
je pense qu'il était ouvert et surtout à
l écoute des enseignants donc je suis
domaine en 2002 emplois et donc
je préfère les services de l'emploi ne
sont pas trés trés on va dire efficace
exactement parce que j'ai fait plusieurs
demandes je n'ai jamais jamais eu de
réponse s'il ya des problèmes galles on
appelle le maire et tout téléphone et ou
là on l'a direct au filet tous les
problèmes psy si par exemple on a des
problèmes de 2,2 d'appartements pour se
loger on va vous pouvez le voir
directement lui en parler tout ça c'est
pas mal voilà les quelques réactions
suite à ce départ de françois de lignes
et de son poste de maire de guyancourt
le socialiste elle sera remplacée à ce
poste nouvelles élections au sein du
conseil municipal d'ici le mois de
décembre et puis je précise que le maire
de gouy encore n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer pour le moment directement
face à notre caméra pour répondre à nos
journalistes nous restons dans cette
commune pour la suite de ce journal avec
un sujet qui touche directement au
quotidien des habitants le mail des
soldes va faire peau neuve les arbres de
l'avenue qui sont malades vont être
abattues à partir de l'été prochain pour
laisser place à un nouveau projet qui a
été présenté d'ailleurs il ya quelques
jours par cette majorité de guyancourt
et ce projet fait grincer quelques dents
le reportage de nicolas kirillovitch
ils ont presque 40 ans ils sont beaucoup
plus âgés que les bâtiments alentour les
225 soul dumail vont devoir pourtant
être abattus d'ici quelques mois en
cause un terrain qui s'affaisse par
certains endroits et un champignon qui
tue progressivement les arbres la mairie
a donc présenté récemment un nouveau
projet aux habitants lors d'une réunion
publique objectif redessiné la venue ce
projet propose de ramener la circulation
piétons vélos poussettes valise etc au
centre dumas y
et de recréer
avertissements de part et d'autre du my
en éloignant les arbres ce qu'il y aura
des arbres bien entendu en éloignant les
arbres des habitations des immeubles le
nouveau projet devrait coûter 4 millions
d'euros entièrement financés par la
ville qui espère une aide de
l'agglomération et si l'utilité des
travaux est reconnu par tous
le projet est sujet à quelques critiques
la future avenue de 500 mètres ne
prévoit qu'une seule allée centrale
contre 2 actuellement et pourrait
engendrer des problèmes de sécurité
entre piétons et cyclistes par exemple
on s'aperçoit lorsqu'on circule à vélo
effectivement que six mètres de large
s'est certes large mais quand il ya du
monde comme tout à l'heure la sortie du
lycée hôtelier par exemple il y à des
conflits entre piétons et cyclistes donc
il vaudrait mieux moins deux bandes
séparés - large 1 mètre 50 on considère
que c'est parfait pour les cyclistes
mais on est absolument certain que ça va
générer des conflits légumes courtes ont
jusqu'au 2 novembre pour faire part de
leurs remarques sur un registre installé
à la maison de quartier augusto renoir
la fin des travaux est prévue elle pour
l'actualité aujourd'hui c'est également
ce lundi matin une quarantaine de taxi
qui ont manifesté devant le siège de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ils dénoncent
l'arrivée de 26 autres taxis
supplémentaires dans les nouvelles
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
plaisir ville preuve encore les
clayes-sous-bois il estime cette
concurrence déloyale une fille qui
n'arrive à faire aujourd'hui non sur ces
trois communes c'est qu'ils vont plus
défendre l'état cris de plaisir et de
vie privée des clayes-sous-bois ils vont
plus descendre dans leur commune pour
faire le boulot en heures de pointe ne
vont pas descendre à plaisir dans les
bouchons les contres avec duff
saint-quentin et puis elle a la garde
et prendre de notre travail alors que
nous on est submergé de concurrence
déloyale par rapport aux savez au
dossier
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on n'était même pas
concertés dans tout l'est des filion qui
puisse y avoir sur le sujet de taxi et
cette action était reçue par la
communauté d'agglomération concernant
les différentes revendications cette
dernière s'engage à réfléchir pour
proposer être des solutions viables
plusieurs réunions avec les villes
concernées sont aussi prévues dans les
prochaines semaines est saint quentin en
yvelines qui souhaitent aider
taxi à être plus visibles sur le terrain
et donc plus efficace et à maintenir
leur chiffre d'affaires à nouveau mécène
pour versailles et son château pour la
première fois le groupe renault a
accepté de participer à la rénovation et
d'une pièce de l'édifice l'annoncé a été
faite ce lundi matin par catherine
pégard la présidente elle de
l'établissement en présence vous l'avez
vu de carlos ghosn le directeur général
du groupe constructeur automobile le
groupe qui n'a pas souhaité donner le
montant de ce mécénat nouveau chantier
et qui concerne le salon de la paix il
est situé dans le prolongement de la
galerie des glaces rénovation qui
débutera en 2017 pour 18 mois le
reportage complet dans notre édition de
demain marty économie à présent et cette
réalité les commerces de centre ville
peinent à se maintenir face à la
concurrence des grands centres
commerciaux dur en effet de survivre
pour les petites enseignes quand les
grandes elles peuvent se permettre de
casser les prix face à ce phénomène un
groupement a décidé d'organiser la
troisième journée nationale du commerce
de proximité
le reportage à maurepas où la résistance
s'est organisée vous allez le voir et
c'est plutôt festif avec anne-laure
longueil sur des images de nicolas
kirillovitch
soleil et bonne humeur à l'ouverture de
cette journée dédiée au commerce de
proximité
depuis plusieurs années nos repas 19
mille habitants déplorent la fermeture
de ces petites enseignes en cause des
affaires qui se porte mal ou des
boutiques qui ne trouve pas un repreneur
la libraire a disparu il faut remettre
une librairie parce que sinon y'a plus
libre il faut aller à trappes wawa
l'encours chercher son journal les gens
ne veulent pas bouger maintenant ils
préfèrent prendre leur voiture à lui
maintenant avec les drives même m même
les grandes surfaces sont touchés à ce
niveau là là c'est foutu pour le
commerce un résultat le centre ville
perd de son dynamisme en 2014 le taux de
vacance commercial atteignait 15 % en
ile-de-france un déclin qui touche
particulièrement les communes de moins
de cent mille habitants
celle ci ne bénéficie pas de
l'attractivité touristique des
métropoles alors la résistance des
riverains se met en place c'est à nous
en tant que riverain de favoriser quand
on peut le petit commerce plutôt que
d'aller systématiquement aller dans les
grandes enseignes
car au delà de la qualité du produit
c'est une expérience de consommation
chaleureuse que les habitants
recherchent avec le commerce de
proximité
nous sommes proches de nos clients avant
tout et donc on essaye de
continuer ainsi nous ce qui compte c'est
la fidélité
depuis trente huit ans un pratiquement
que nous sommes ici d'abord quoi
voilà ce qui fait que nous existons
encore et on espère encore très
longtemps ici les élus se battent pour
freiner la fermeture des petits
commerces malgré une marge de manoeuvre
réduite
je reçois des messages de mort patients
qui me disent qu'ils sont évidemment
attaché alors leur commerce local
d'autant plus que quand vous avez des
cellules qui sont vides où vous avez des
commerces qui s'en vont les mortuaciens
s'adresse directement mer alors que j'ai
pas forcément la main dans le sens où ce
sont des activités privées et donc le
rang d'une musicalité c'est
d'accompagner décidé de renouveler en
tout cas les activités de faire en sorte
de savoir qui est propriétaire des murs
qui est propriétaire des fonds qui
propriétaire des baux pour accompagner à
l'échelle régionale les collectivités
locales investissent elles aussi dans le
maintien du commerce de proximité le
futur réseau de transport grand paris
express doit desservir en priorité les
centres-villes
rapidement un mode de culture pour
terminer ce journal du début de semaine
ce week end la bd était à l'honneur à
buc samedi et dimanche se tenait le
traditionnel festival de la bande
dessinée dans le parc du château
cinquante auteurs adultes jeunesse
français et internationaux qui ont fait
le déplacement parmi le baptême c'est le
père de la fiche de cette édition et
dessinateur du marsupilami également et
rock étaient présents ses moteurs et des
profs elle réside dans le département
des yvelines et puis il y avait aussi
des auteurs venus de chine deux jours
consacrés aux dédicaces et aux
rencontres comme vous avez pu vous en
apercevoir on écoute fabry diop et rosie
ils illustrent les personnages du monde
de mickey depuis maintenant 22 ans
c'est une occasion opportunités
très intéressant pour un dessinateur
disney et de rencontrer des gens les
fans de ce monde il y a deux différents
types de public il ya les enfants et les
nostalgiques
les enfants qu'ils aiment qu'ils
achètent toujours rejoindre un ami qui
joue d'autres collections busines
actuelle et à côté de ça il ya aussi les
fans les gens qui ont
ni disney et qu'on dit et du tout jeune
se colle très bien pour pouvoir aussi
avoir un échange avec les gens
les enfants qui sont toujours très
content de voir par magie surgir dessins
de mickey donald c'est la fin de ce
journal on se retrouve demain mardi pour
un nouveau point complet sur l'actualité
locale
[Musique]